and here are the questions from people
Kara do you agree with Joe Biden that
Mark Zuckerberg is a quote real problem
I don't know quite what he meant by that
I think there's issues around mark and
leading of Facebook you know I didn't
think there's regular I don't know if
he's a real problem but he's definitely
making decisions that are problematic
including the political advertising
micro targeting and that others have
spent more time but when you're
thoughtful about you know I kind of
defended him on that he's saying we're
not gonna correct lies but you know it's
such a slippery slope what is a line
what is not I don't know of course I
know when Trump is lying but other
politicians have lied it's by degree
between paid advertising and free speech
and I think they're talking paid speech
and free speech are two different things
right trying to conflate them together
and they're not that's a great point
right okay cable networks have said that
they'll actually take responsibility if
a paid ad is verifiably false so if the
cable network can do it I don't see how
Facebook with vastly greater levels of
resources can't do it Andrew do you have
any thoughts on the you have any
thoughts on the new Iowa caucus rules
that could result in three different
sets of winners I'm not up on that
you'll have to yes everybody gets a
trophy they were pushing towards a
virtual caucus and they pulled back on
that and so this time there including
vote count which is unusual so you might
win a vote count and then there's a
delegate count right there's a counting
vote count what would they do before but
before so it's a complicated system
where you have to be viable in a
particular area and then you get
delegates assigned based upon
proportions but then they're also
including raw votes so it's in theory
more transparent it's going to be a
little bit confusing could be messy it
could be messy but we're excited I'm
flying right from here to Iowa I have a
17 day bus tour your friend Norm
Macdonald is going to come around some I
always one of the young gang he is
[Applause]
I've been all the time but the Iowa
caucus it Sandia can you get the
Senators can't campaign there because
they're at the impeachment trial so you
have less competition out there at the
diner yes the bus traffic will be a
little bit later Joe what do you think
should happen to Devin Nunez now that we
know about his association with live
piranhas oh my god you served with yeah
you must know Devin quite well I think
I think he's in trouble he's in clear
legal trouble I don't know possibly but
he and partes were like best friends
communicating on this deal he was part
of it he denied even knew the guy he's
in some trouble alright John were you
surprised to read the Trump called his
generals hopes and babies surprised
about anything yeah or are the
revelations in a very stable genius just
more of the crazy old Trump this is the
book I referenced there and the yeah
Phil Rutger and his colleague right I
just ordered it I haven't read it yet
but I've asked Andrew actually to see if
he would mind having a lapel pin that
says nonfiction hardback books you win
good for you I think that yeah I think
the book will tell us I suspect is what
a lot of these other books have told us
which is they give us it's like The
Wizard of Oz it's we know the black and
white and then they get to Oz and it's
in color right right there are details
that fill it out but how do we know it's
true I mean of course it's believable
anything about these are some amazing
reporters yeah so what but they weren't
in the room it's almost they're probably
getting it from Rex Tillerson he seems
like the hero I feel like I've seen this
movie with Bob Woodward like we read a
book of his and it's really because he
had
Pawel saying Colin powers izakaya I love
Colin Powell but you're getting his
story well it seems like we're getting
Rex Tillerson everybody around the guy
says he's a [ __ ] well we know he's a
moral I know but even beyond that I mean
I don't unless I have two people to
write okay well I again extreme
extremely believable that he would say
that but I think a bigger issue is that
he has I keep saying he suffers
everything comes from the fact that he
suffers from narcissistic personality
disorder
only a narcissist who cannot project
anything in the future anything that's a
would say to his top brass you're morons
I wouldn't go to war with you yeah
that's so self-destructive in so many
ways actually it's entertaining he's
doing this is entertainment one of the
things that was in the book was amazing
is that this is a show he said that
nobody was there there was no audience
there how could that be the entire thing
is over for him but this was a private
meeting with his brass playing it in his
head this is a really nice women I feel
like I'm the only person where I watched
every apprentice if you watch all the
apprentices and I did I swear cuz you
liked it I did was your guilty pleasure
to show what Temptation Island for me
okay it's entertainment for him and then
he then does Twitter and it's a
call-and-response and he calls into fox
it's all and he's bully it's also just
bullying right and the one thing that
did surprise me is he likes the way the
generals look
yeah that's thing to me forecasting yeah
and so to turn on them it must have been
a particularly good he's done it so many
times he's all everybody he's starting
with I mean when that when does the
whole thing I knew was gonna go to [ __ ]
when he's at the beginning of the
campaign said McCain not a war hero
I like heroes who were not captured and
they did not react they did not throw
him out of that race he likes the rage
it's lather rinse repeat and really
lather is but that was the real test
like were the Republicans gonna say oh
my god that is against everything we
have ever stood for and believed in and
this is one of our heroes and I'm sorry
but you are just persona no
in this party and it didn't happen and I
was like oh now he's gonna do he could
have not have won the nomination after
always would have happened before if
somebody had said John McCain is not a
war hero it did
who doesn't matter it's a Republican so
out of them did a lot of them much more
than you think so and it just hits exalt
the whole thing is who said that I'd
love to know maybe I don't over and over
again people are shocked by this
behavior and they guy can't believe he
said that at some point I was like
believe it he says it all he does but
nobody oh right just him Billy's a
demagogue and it worked because a lot of
as Andrew said a lot of people wanted to
believe in Michigan Wisconsin and
Pennsylvania he was going to deliver
baby he was a demagogue and people
bought that I go schools got a must
how's the campaign going are you getting
any traction from people yes we're
pulling at 14% in I in in Florida you've
got 14 14 person can vote a poll came
out yesterday
[Applause]
you